El comportamiento
está escrito en los genes.
Todos los animales tenemos
comportamientos innatos,
comportamientos con los que nacemos.
Comportamientos que con la evolución
se fueron haciendo cada vez más complejos.
En muchos aspectos,
el comportamiento de machos y hembras
de la misma especie es distinto,
y estas diferencias en el comportamiento
están dadas por diferencias
en el cableado del sistema nervioso.
Estas diferencias de cableado, a su vez,
están establecidas genéticamente.
La agresión es un comportamiento que,
en general, es específico de los machos.
Lo vemos en especies
que son muy distintas,
que están alejadas evolutivamente.
La forma en que pelea
cada una de estas especies es diferente,
pero los mecanismos son parecidos.
Las razones son casi siempre las mismas.
Los machos pelean por hembras,
por comida o por territorio.
Yo estudio agresión en moscas.
Lo que van a ver ahora es un ataque.
Un animal se va a incorporar
y va a dejar caer todo el peso
de su cuerpo sobre su oponente.
El otro, mientras tanto,
va a tratar de escaparse.
¿Por qué estudio agresión en moscas?
Porque el comportamiento
que me interesa entender es el mismo
y el sistema mucho más simple.
Entonces es como estudiar una maqueta.
A veces pasa que el otro animal,
en lugar de escaparse,
se queda y empieza a pelear,
y entonces se da algo
que llamamos "boxeo".
Algo muy importante del ataque
es que solamente los machos lo hacen.
El que primero atacó,
es mucho más probable que gane.
Los machos solo atacan a otros machos,
las hembras nunca atacan.
Entonces, ¿por qué estudiar
comportamiento en moscas?
Tienen nuestros mismos comportamientos:
las moscas duermen, comen, cortejan,
pelean, aprenden y recuerdan.
El sistema nervioso es mucho más simple,
y además, los genes que intervienen
en este comportamiento son muy parecidos.
Entonces, estudiar agresión en moscas
nos permite entender cómo se desarrolla
este mismo comportamiento
en otras especies.
Un elemento clave a la hora
de decidir si cortejar o atacar
es determinar el sexo del otro animal.
Todos los machos están programados
para decidir entre cortejo o agresión,
pero las claves sensoriales
que usan para ver si es un macho
o una hembra son distintas;
por ejemplo, en nuestra especie
las claves visuales son muy importantes.
Lo que una mosca tiene adelante es esto.
Entonces, ¿cómo decide?
Evidentemente, de alguna manera decide,
porque lo hace en cada caso
es muy distinto.
En presencia de un macho
que entra en su territorio,
va a empezar a atacar
y a perseguirlo por todos lados
hasta que el otro decida escaparse.
En presencia de una hembra,
le arrastra el ala.
Como pueden ver,
literalmente le arrastra el ala.
La persigue por todos lados,
le canta hasta que finalmente
la conquista.
Entonces la pregunta es: ¿cómo lo sabe?
¿Cómo decide?
¿Cuáles son las claves sensoriales
que usa para decidir si tiene que cortejar
o si tiene que atacar?
Y si podemos identificar estas claves,
¿podemos cambiarlas?
¿Podemos invertir esta decisión?
En insectos, como en muchas especies,
son muy importantes las señales químicas
que se llaman feromonas.
Estas señales son producidas por un animal
y detectadas por el otro.
Entonces, lo que decidimos hacer
fue invertir las feromonas,
cambiar el perfume.
Para hacer eso, manipulamos la expresión
de un gen que se llama "transformer".
"Transformer" está prendido en las hembras
y apagado en los machos.
Entonces, algo que podemos hacer
es silenciar "transformer" en las hembras
y forzar su adquisición en los machos.
Con esto, masculinizamos hembras
y feminizamos machos.
Pero no en todos lados,
no vamos a manipular todo el animal.
Vamos a elegir algunas partes;
en particular,
las células que hacen feromonas.
Entonces, lo que podemos lograr
son hembras que tienen
feromonas masculinas
o machos que tienen feromonas femeninas.
Y entonces vamos a ver qué va a pasar
cuando un macho normal, no manipulado,
se encuentra con una hembra
que tiene feromonas masculinas.
Y lo que pasa es que la ataca.
Cuando ella entra a su territorio,
él hace algo que nunca haría
frente a una hembra normal,
que es empezar a atacarla.
Cuando hacemos el experimento recíproco,
lo que encontramos es que los machos
que tienen feromonas femeninas
son cortejados.
¿Esto qué quiere decir?
Que los machos están genéticamente
programados para cortejar
cuando encuentran feromonas femeninas
y para atacar cuando encuentran
feromonas masculinas.
Pero, este comportamiento,
este comportamiento innato
que está cableado en el cerebro,
cortejar si hay feromonas femininas,
atacar si hay feromonas masculinas,
¿se puede cambiar?
¿Puede ser que un animal
tan simple como una mosca
pueda aprender de su experiencia
y modificar un comportamiento
que es innato?
¿Algo que está cableado
en su sistema nervioso?
Para responder esta pregunta,
hicimos un experimento parecido.
Otra vez, manipulamos "transformer",
pero esta vez,
en el cerebro de las hembras.
Estas hembras tienen todavía
feromonas femeninas,
pero se comportan como machos.
Silenciamos "transformer" en el cerebro,
son hembras agresivas.
No solamente que no les gusta nada
ser cortejadas, sino que atacan.
Entonces nos preguntamos,
¿qué va a hacer un macho
cuando se encuentre con una hembra
que tiene feromonas de hembra
pero es agresiva?
Y lo primero que va a hacer
es cortejarla por todos lados.
La persigue, la persigue,
le arrastra el ala, le canta,
pero llega un momento que decide
cambiar su comportamiento.
Llega un momento que de tanto cortejarla
y que no pase nada,
y que ella encima lo ataque
dice "Bueno ya".
Y la termina atacando.
Esto quiere decir que aún un animal
tan simple como una mosca
puede aprender de su experiencia
y modificar su comportamiento.
Y no solo esto.
Cuando hay peleas entre dos machos,
siempre se da que hay
un ganador y un perdedor.
Después de que un macho
perdió muchas veces
lo que ocurre es que suprime
este comportamiento.
Deja de pelear.
Esto quiere decir que aún
en un animal tan simple como una mosca
el comportamiento está en los genes,
pero la capacidad
de aprender de la experiencia
y modificarlo, también.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)